aquí tenemos un motor habíamos hablado
de los diferentes componentes en el
motor y cómo funcionan así que voy a
tratar de hablar acerca del motor que
hicimos y mostrarles las similitudes con
el motor que tenemos aquí por ejemplo
estos de aquí son imanes permanentes y
se comportan como como este tipo de kim
es decir como el imán permanente que
tiene la secadora de cabello nuestro
motor tiene sus polos opuestos es decir
este es el imán norte y este es el imán
sur y si los pones juntos se pegarán
porque los polos opuestos se atraen bien
y estos puedo supuesto son importantes
tanto como la armadura que está
representada por este tipo de bobina que
da vueltas y así continúa moviéndose y
este de aquí es el conmutador el cual es
un poco difícil de ver porque es este
cable de cobre que ha sido pelado
pelamos el aislante del cable de cobre
en este lado pero lo dejamos en el otro
el problema es que el aislante es
realmente una laca transparente por lo
que es difícil de ver pero
que hicimos fue pelarlo con un cuchillo
lo que significa que esta sección del
cable de cobre está siendo lo mismo que
el conmutador del motor eléctrico y si
observas por aquí las escobillas que son
las que conducen la electricidad del
contacto que tenemos aquí hasta el
conmutador van a ser sustituidas por las
arandelas porque funcionan como las
escobillas ellas van a conducir la
electricidad desde la batería hasta el
conmutador o cable este que tenemos aquí
y después van a conducir la energía a
través de la bobina am o bueno la
armadura y después la van a conducir
hasta el otro lado regresando de nuevo a
la batería y así completando el circuito
y todo esto lo que está haciendo es
crear un electroimán el cual está
resistiendo los imanes permanentes de
aquí y provocan que este mecanismo de
vueltas y entonces gire el ventilador
que gira de la misma manera que el motor
del ventilador de nuestra secadora de
cabello así que vamos a ver cómo
funciona en nuestra secadora de cabello
un interruptor que cuando reaccionamos
hace que el ventilador empiece a girar y
en él ocurre lo mismo puedes ver el
motor girar
y cuando apagamos el interruptor dejará
de girar